welcome to the call today i want to open
the floor up
to ask you guys because i'm sure because
it's been it's been 30 days since last
time we spoke
so if you guys have questions in the
chat burning burning things decisions
that are impending
things you are unsure about strategies
that you need to validate or even just a
a verbal high five please put in the
chat and then um
i'll go i'll go from top to bottom jason
bring you on a business partner
don't do it and go ahead
so i've had this business
for over a decade and legion's just ne
it's always been my weakest function
and um i'm more i follow you real quick
what's that can i pause you real quick
on that one
how many hours a day do you spend
working on legion
not a lot because i get caught up in
other stuff yeah so
so you think about doing a partnership
with kyle and you're making the
consideration you want to know the
decision process is that right
uh yeah i mean a i want to know if it
was a good idea
which i know there's risks involved so
then i'm like
what what are the risks and what
consideration i'm meeting with elizabeth
morgan this evening
to bring up my concerns but i wanted to
get your feedback because you've
probably
seen a lot you've been i've had eight
filled partnerships so i know nothing
about this
is you have to have re like talk about
all the ugly [ __ ] first
yeah right so right now you guys are in
lust right you guys are like making
out getting you know having having sales
sex and just like it's
things are amazing right you don't want
to have the really ugly like how are we
going to split up alimony if we you know
if we get divorced later conversation
exit strategy all that yeah so
like that's what has to get defined and
you now could define roles and
responsibilities
the only reason to have a partner is if
if they have skills you do not have
or they have money you don't have or
they have time you don't have if you're
on the flip side
like you have money and they have time
right so
that's where that's where partnerships
are useful the number one way most
people do partnerships though is like
hey i'm cool
you're cool we love the same thing let's
go into business together
which is a terrible way to do a
partnership because one of you is not
necessary
right and you're just diluting your
equity said are you looking at doing a
true partnership or are you looking on
doing like a minority type deal
um i would always maintain a majority
and it would be a scaling
you know my big company's an s corp so
he would basically get
a piece of the company as he helps me
hit certain million dollar milestones
at to the point of max maybe like a
third of the company
okay well that's that's different that's
more like a performance-based
relationship
with kickers i would i would structure
it as phantom equity
which means what so it's equity that
doesn't actually invest
unless there is a sale and if he were to
leave then he doesn't get the equity
and so you can pair those two things
together so you can do like equity with
profit sharing
and so that that would be that would be
probably how i would structure it
either profit or rev share depending on
you know how you negotiate it
okay
but just as a just a side note for
everyone on here like
i remember i had a mentor really early
on he's like and i was i was taking on
all these partners left and right
because i didn't know what i was doing
and uh he's like listen you're gonna
need an accountant he's like
you just pay the accountant he's like
he's not a part he's not a partner in my
business he's like i just
pay an accountant right so it's like
just because you have a need doesn't
mean they have to be equity owner
right there's plenty of companies that
are owned by people who are not lead
generation specialists
you know so i think if it were me i'd
probably try and set up a really
lucrative relationship
that isn't necessarily a partnership so
i'd say like
you know it's pay per or eight
percentage of
something something to that extent right
i don't know if you're ever planning on
selling because the only reason someone
would ever want equity is
if they want control or they want to be
able to make money on an exit
so the only two reasons you want equity
otherwise equity sucks
because then you just have liability
which blows
so unless he wants control which i don't
think he does and unless you think
you're gonna sell which i don't think
you are
or i don't think you want to just you've
been doing it for a decade unless you're
just
sick and tired of it but i don't get
that impression
right so then the only thing that that
he should want or that you should
probably negotiate for is the stuff that
he wants which is a percentage of
revenue
or percentage of profit based on xyz so
i think that's what you should i don't
think you need to make this an equity
partnership
at all i think you just need an
agreement um
okay does that make sense
yeah you need an import a performance
agreement this is like standard you know
there's tons of e-commerce companies
that like they take ten percent of top
line from
from sales attributed to the marketing
that they make and they're full service
they don't have equity in the company
but they get they get a percentage of
revenue
got it yeah i guess i have to
see or talk to kyle and figure out like
why would equity matter to him because
yeah i'd be like just say what do you
want
or the or control but right just ask
what do you want
he's probably gonna say i want to
participate in the upside cool what
specifically because if it's
sale i'm not going to sell so what
specifically i want to p i want a piece
of what i'm bringing it
cool so then let's do it based on do
exercise x or y
for you it'd be advertised to do profit
share for him it'd be advantageous to do
a rupture
it's up to you
right okay
that makes sense and the next question
looks like it's relevant
peter's gonna exit yeah okay so peter
this is for you
how to sever ties with a business
partner and best practices go separate
ways
so it depends on whether you have a kid
or not right and how good looking the
kid is and how much money the kid makes
right and so you guys have a business if
the business isn't making a ton of money
then most of these times you can just be
like hey man like why don't we just both
[ __ ] off
and go our separate ways it's even worse
than the business isn't making any money
and has
debt that needs to be paid off so then
you can just i mean then at that point
you should just split the debt
if you want to if you like you can split
the debt or you can um
is this an llc that you are ending or is
this in general
so so the way the business is set up is
it is an llc
and then i have obviously my own agency
so the
to the idea was to use my agency to
generate sales to then pay the debt
of the other llc back however
um i'm responsible for the back end he's
responsible for the front end like the
sales
yeah last six months he hasn't really
brought in any sales so now that i'm
selling and doing everything
exactly it becomes their point of like
okay this debt is 50 50
however if i'm doing 100 of the work why
should i also pay 100
of the debt and fulfill the product and
do everything else on the back end
yeah i mean trying to figure out like
how to uh rip that band-aid off and
say you know
the easiest way to easiest way to have
have hard conversations is just ask the
questions that you ask here
so like literally the biggest hack in
all of relationships is the way that you
talk [ __ ] about someone behind their
back is literally what you should just
tell them
so it's like hey man you said that you
were gonna do all the
sales and i was gonna do the back end
well you're not doing the sales but
we're still both responsible for this
thing
so what do you think's fair
you'll have what you have in mind but a
lot of times people who once you once
you present the information like that
it'll be like
ah [ __ ] you're right you're like so what
do you think's fair
he's like well you should just take the
business and um
i guess i can try and start paying off
my my share over time you're like cool
that's what i was thinking too
let's sign these that way the you know
the things dissolved and then uh
you transfer your equity to me and you
have a note
back to me for 50 of the debt
cool does that make sense yeah you can
google promissory note
template one page it's just like
from borrower to lender no interest x
amount by this
paid by this state in this increment
like
what what happens if they default and
that's it
like it's a very simple like i've done
million dollar loans on one page like
you're there they hold up
and you're in real estate so you should
find plenty of promise orders that are
simple
yeah that makes sense so there's the
equity that's
where investors are to our lenders right
so i want to make sure like
so this the equity and the debt so
there's two pieces right
the equity you just say hey i own 100 of
this company
you're giving your shares to me because
you're not doing [ __ ]
right that's number one or we dissolve
the company i create new entity i'd
prefer to say 300
what's up to you right the thing is is
you could do that right now it doesn't
like and you could just say like i don't
really give a [ __ ] if you sign this and
it saves me 300 bucks like this is not
really discussion because there's
nothing here
right the the second piece is uh
is okay now let's now that we've dealt
with the equity piece now let's deal
with the debt piece
right and so the debt piece this is what
we both owe this is what we agreed on
this is what i will do
and this is the promissory note that you
can write you know or we can both sign
together towards the lenders
okay make sense and then you get then
you're done
yeah and then as far as his involvement
my agency just
he can quote unquote sell my product and
earn a commission and do whatever he
seems with it or or not because that's
the other
you know tricky part is he's also
involved in my agency
but more so because you guys are making
any money so it's not like he's gonna
start making money now
yeah okay right yeah that's kind of what
i'm thinking as well
yeah it's like let's let's obsess about
the fact that it's like what if he gets
rich on my products he wasn't getting
rich on your [ __ ] product for the
last two years so like i don't think
it's just
you know what i mean you know my my
thing was like i wanted i want him to
pull some sales in for us to actually
sell the product because then we would
actually pay the other thing
that's fine then i would say and on top
of this i'll still continue to give you
the
the thing you can still sell it and you
know we split the revenue whatever
yeah okay cool
sweet